um you mentioned kind of like
how you determine if you can trust
somebody and i know you've said in the
past you've kind of used buffett's
criteria for evaluating people which is
the combination of intelligence energy
and integrity what person what
predictive signals do you pay attention
to for each how do you determine if you
can trust someone a large part of your
job that's the hardest one
yeah integrity is the hardest one and
integrity is uh it usually comes out in
two ways one is long term which is just
you've known somebody for a while and
you kind of know you know how to think
about things
but the most the more interesting one
there's a short term one which is you
just kind of see how they treat other
people so there are lots and lots of
people who will uh you know not screw
over scrubber is a strong word but they
will do something that is self-feeling
or slightly unethical um relative to
another business partner um but the
whole time they'll they'll say to you
i you know i'm taking advantage of that
person because they deserve it but
you're my friend i would never do that
to you
and the thing is yeah exactly it's very
easy to change your definition of who
friends are
i find the people who really do it
things out of integrity they have an
internal moral compass so they don't
uh they don't do
unfair unethical or bad deals with other
people because it would soil their own
view of themselves and they wouldn't be
able to sleep with themselves at night
so some of the highest integrity people
i know the worst thing you can do is you
consider them well i think you're
self-dealing on that one and they will
get so unhappy because they'll be like
no no no that's not who i am i can't be
that person and they'll bend over
backwards yeah usually i find that
people that i negotiate with who are
high integrity they'll they're very easy
to negotiate with they'll give you
things that they don't need to give you
because they think it's fair and vice
versa so negotiations with high
integrity people are usually very easy
you're giving each other things to make
sure the other person's happy enough
that the deal survives because unhappy
deals get unwound and they become
short-term relationships which don't
have any compounding benefits and then
finally if someone is going around and
talking about how honest they are
they're probably dishonest
that's just like a little telltale
indicator i've learned when someone
spends too much time talking about their
own values or talking themselves up
they're covering for something um so
there's actually a good book it's kind
of out of print i think it's hard to
track down maybe you can find it online
somewhere and uh it's not the obvious
one the name of the book is called the
art of manipulation
um and i found it because of a tweet
that i followed from illa certain
and it was really good it was because
this guy basically goes undercover and
lives with con men uh and he spends time
with him running cons and learning all
about cons and he's just very
uh without judgment he just laid down
how con con men work uh and he puts down
their how to spot them when they're
being dishonest and some of the telltale
signs are they will they'll push the
deal a little bit too hard they'll sell
just a little bit too hard they'll talk
about how honest they are
but
i have great people in my life who are
extremely successful
very desirable like everybody wants to
be their friend very smart uh and yet
i've seen them do one or two things that
are slightly not great to other people
and the first time i'll tell them i'll
go up and say hey look i don't i don't
think you should do that to that other
person not because
you won't get away with it you will get
away with it but because it'll hurt you
in the end not in some cosmic karma kind
of way but just i i believe that deep
down we all know who we are
you cannot hide anything from yourself
and so your own failures are written
within your psyche and they're obvious
to you and so if you have too many of
these moral shortcomings you will not
respect yourself and the worst the worst
outcome in this world is not having
self-esteem if you don't love yourself
who will
so i think that you just have to be very
careful about doing things that you were
fundamentally not going to be proud of
because they will damage you so the
first time around i warned them by the
way nobody changes right uh and then i
just kind of distance myself from them
they just sort of you know cut cut them
out of my life like i
i i just had this saying inside my head
the closer you want to get to me the
better your values have to be
um
yeah when i met my wife it was a great
test because
uh i really wanted to be with her and
she wasn't so sure at the beginning and
so and in the end we ended up together
because she saw my values
and i'm lucky i had developed them by
that point because if i hadn't i
wouldn't have gotten her not that i own
her or anything there's no attachment
like that but but i wouldn't have
deserved her that's like as charlie
munger says to find a worthy mate be
worthy of a worthy mate
so i think it you know working on your
values is long-term selfish although
short-term it's absolutely involved
sacrifices if being ethical were
profitable everybody would do it and we
wouldn't have to have a separate concept
we wouldn't talk about it there would be
no books on it there would be no no one
would ever talk about values because
it'd be profitable but it's not it's
obviously unprofitable it involves
sacrifices but like everything in life
if you're willing to make the short-term
sacrifice you'll have the long-term
benefit
my physical trainer
jersey gregoric really wise brilliant
guy he always says uh you know
easy choices hard life hard choices easy
life
so basically if you're making the hard
choices right now and what to eat you're
not eating all the junk food you want
being a hard choice to work out then
your life long term will be easy you
won't be sick you won't be unhealthy
same is true of value same is true of
saving up for any day same is true of
how you approach your relationships but
if you make the easy choices right now
your overall life will be a lot harder i
would like to talk for just one minute
up to the students about your
about your future when you leave here
because there's
you're going to learn a tremendous
amount about investments and you'll
learn
you'll learn enough to do well you've
all got the iq to do well
you've all got the initiative and energy
to do well or you wouldn't be you
wouldn't be here
uh and most of you will succeed
in in in in meeting your aspirations uh
but
in in determining whether you succeed
uh there's more to it than intellect
and energy and i'd like to talk for just
a second about that in fact
there was a fellow that
pete keywood in omaha used to say that
he looked with
three things
in hiring people look for integrity
intelligence and energy and he said if
the person didn't have the first two
that the latter two would kill them
because if they don't have integrity you
want them dumb and lazy you don't want
them smart and energetic
and i really like to talk about that
first one because we we know you've got
the second two and and i did play along
with me in a little game for just a
second uh and in terms of thinking about
that question
you've all been here i guess almost all
of your second year mbas and you've
gotten to know your classmates and think
for a moment that i granted you the
right
to buy 10
of one of your classmates
for the rest of his or her lifetime
um
now you can't pick one with a rich
father that doesn't count i mean you've
got to uh you've got to pick them pick
somebody who's going to do it on their
own merit and
and i gave you an hour to think about it
which one are you going to pick among
all your classmates is for the one you
want to own ten percent of for the rest
of their lifetime
and are you gonna give an iq test
pick the one with the highest iq i doubt
it
are you gonna pick the one with the best
grades
uh
i doubt it
uh
you're not even gonna pick the most
energetic one necessarily you're the one
that displays the most initiative but
you're going to start looking for
qualitative factors in addition because
everybody's got enough right here and
enough energy
and i would say that if you thought
about it for an hour decided who you're
going to place that bet on
you'd probably pick
the one who you responded the best to
because the one that was going to have
the leadership qualities the ones that
are going to be able to get other people
to carry out
their interests and that would be the
person who was generous and honest and
who gave credit to other people even
for their own ideas all kinds of
qualities like that and you could write
down those qualities that you admire in
this other person whoever you admire
most in the class
and then i would throw in a hooker i
would say as part of owning 10 of this
person you had to agree to go short 10
of somebody else in the class
that's more fun is it
and you think well now who do i want to
go short of and uh
uh again you wouldn't pick the person
with the lowest iq or the or you you
would you would start thinking about the
person really who turned you off for one
reason or another i mean advertising
various qualities
quite apart from their academic
achievement but they had various
qualities in the engine shouldn't really
want to be around them and other people
didn't want to be around them and what
were the qualities that lead to that
well there'd be a whole bunch of things
you know but it's the person who's
egotistic all the person who's greedy
the person who
slightly dishonest cuts corners all of
these qualities and you can write those
down on the right hand side of the page
and when you look at that we'll just
i don't know which one i'm using can you
hear me okay with this you have to find
it
yeah
you can see why i avoid technology
chewing gum is about as far as i get uh
as you looked at those qualities on the
left and right hand side there's one
interesting thing about them it's not
the ability to throw a football 60 yards
uh it's not it's not the ability to run
the hundred yard dash in nine three it's
not being the best-looking person in the
class they're all
qualities
that if you really want to have the ones
on the left-hand side you can have them
i mean they are they're qualities of
behavior temperament character
that that are achievable they're not
forbidden to anybody in this group
and if you look at the qualities on the
right-hand side the ones that you find
turn you off in other people
there's not there's not a quality there
that you have to have if you have it you
can you can you can
you can get rid of it
and you can get rid of a lot easier at
your age than you can at my age because
uh most behaviors is habitual and they
say the chains of habit are too light to
be felt until they're too heavy to be
broken
and there's no question about i see
people with these self-destructive
behavior patterns
at my age or even 10 or 20 years younger
and they really are entrapped by them
they they go around and they do things
that turn off other people
right and left and
they don't need to be that way but by a
certain point they get so they can
hardly change it but at your age you can
have any any any habits
any any patterns of behavior that you
wish it's simply a question of which you
decide
and why not decide the ones that i mean
if you like ben graham did this ben
franklin did it beforehand but then ben
graham in his low in his lower teens
looked around and he looked at the
people he admired
and he said you know i want to be
admired so why don't i just behave like
them and he found there was nothing
impossible about behaving like them and
similarly he did the same thing on the
reverse side in terms of getting rid of
those qualities so
i would suggest that if you write those
qualities down and think about them a
little while and make them habitual you
will be the one that you want to buy 10
of when you get all through and the
beauty of it is you already own 100
you're stuck with it so you might as
well you might as well be that person
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you